Traduttore: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Elena Montrasio
Ecco, questo è esattamente
quello che volevo!
Vedevo alcuni volti un po' preoccupati,
smarriti, perplessi.
Altri, invece: "Cosa sta dicendo questa?"
Pochi, invece, quelli che hanno compreso,
perché qui in sala ci sono persone sorde
e udenti che conoscono
anche la lingua dei segni.
Ma tutti voi,
che tipo di sensazione avete provato?
Di vuoto?
Smarrimento?
Ignoto?
Perplessità?
Anche di curiosità, perché no?
Queste sono le stesse
emozioni e sensazioni
che provano le persone sorde,
quando si trovano di fronte
a qualcosa che non è comprensibile,
di fronte a qualcosa
che non è accessibile.
Questo è quello
che proviamo noi, ogni giorno,
in un mondo creato
solo per le persone udenti.
Ora sicuramente sorrido
perché vi chiederete:
"Ah! Ma quindi una persona sorda parla?
E provare a farlo prima, no?"
Il mio obiettivo, questa sera,
è di provare a rispondere
a tutte le domande
che avreste sempre voluto fare
ad una persona sorda
come quei link che ogni tanto
escono sui social:
"Le 10 domande che avreste
sempre voluto fare a..."
Domande spesse volte comuni,
a volte insolite o scomode,
ma domande sempre e comunque
molto importanti,
domande alle quali ho sempre risposto
nel corso della mia vita,
in tutti questi 28 anni,
provando ad abbattere
tutti quei pregiudizi e stereotipi
che da sempre ci sono
intorno al mondo della sordità.
Ad oggi, a una donna italiana incinta
vengono proposti
una serie di test genetici,
molto meno invasivi rispetto
a un'amniocentesi o a una villocentesi.
Tra le malattie genetiche più frequenti
testate sul sangue materno ci sono:
x fragile, beta talassemia,
distrofia muscolare, fibrosi cistica.
E...la sordità congenita.
Malattia!
È forse qui che sta il problema di fondo:
la sordità non è una malattia.
Proviamo allora
a definirla con altri termini:
la sordità è un limite,
la sordità è una mancanza.
Sono due parole oggettive
che possono essere usate
in contesti diversi.
Com'è per noi nascere
in un mondo di silenzio?
La musica?
Come nascono, come sentono
la sveglia le persone sorde?
Boh... mistero!
Ecco che inizia questo viaggio insieme.
Vorrei portarvi con me nel mio mondo,
fatto anche di silenzio,
provando ad abbattere
tutti quei pregiudizi e stereotipi,
provando a condividere con voi
che cosa significa al giorno d'oggi
essere persone sorde.
Vi incuriosirà sapere
che cosa vuol dire
essere "sordi profondi".
Adesso però vi svelo
cosa ho detto all'inizio!
Mi chiamo Ilaria,
ho 28 anni, abito a Bergamo,
sono sorda profonda dalla nascita
per un fattore ereditario,
mi mancano le cellule ciliate
all'interno dalla coclea,
che funzionano da recettori sensoriali.
Sono cioè quelle cellule responsabili
della trasmissione acustica
delle informazioni
al sistema nervoso centrale.
Quindi, che cosa vuol dire
essere sordi profondi?
Nel mio caso è avere una perdita uditiva
che va oltre i 95 decibel.
Che cosa vuol dire?
Vuol dire non sentire
fino a un rumore pari a
(Rumore di aereo che decolla)
Caspita l'ho sentito anche io!
(Risate)
Quindi, signori, vuol dire
non sentire una beata mazza!
(Applausi)
Come avrete capito,
ci sono diversi tipi
e diversi gradi di sordità,
a seconda dalla perdita uditiva
che viene misurata in decibel.
La sordità può essere dalla nascita
oppure insorgere più tardi
per diverse svariate cause.
La mia sordità
l'hanno scoperta a sette mesi:
eravamo in montagna,
in un paesino chiamato Pontegiurino,
dalle parti di Berbenno,
in provincia di Bergamo.
Era una domenica di festa,
eravamo nel sagrato della chiesa
ed erano suonate
all'improvviso le campane.
Tutti, ma proprio tutti,
si erano spaventati:
tranne una, ovviamente io!
E forse è per questo motivo
che mi chiedo spesso, e che si dice:
"Ila, ma sei proprio sorda
come una campana!"
A nove mesi sono stata protesizzata
ed è iniziato un lungo percorso
di musicoterapia e di logopedia.
Oggi in Italia nascono
più di mille bambini sordi ogni anno.
E con screening neonatali,
e con le diagnosi precoci,
molti di questi bambini
intraprendono da subito
un percorso di riabilitazione
alla parola e all'ascolto,
grazie anche all'uso
di protesi acustiche e impianti cocleari.
Recentemente era uscita una foto,
sui social, che è diventata virale
di un dolcissimo papà
che si era tatuato l'impianto cocleare
per far sentire meno sola la sua figlia.
La tecnologia, da questo punto di vista,
sta facendo dei progressi enormi.
Mi preme però precisarvi
che ogni famiglia
fa le sue scelte molto personali
in merito ai percorsi
educativi e riabilitativi
da intraprendere per i propri figli.
Quello che condivido io con voi
è quello che tratta di me,
dalla mia esperienza e dalla mia famiglia.
Io sono cresciuta bilingue:
da mamma udente, papà sordo:
mamma è figlia di genitori sordi,
papà è figlio di genitori udenti,
il fratello di mia madre è udente,
la sorella di papà è sorda,
io ho un fratello, udente,
di quattro anni più grande
e ho cugini sordi, cugini udenti,
insomma, un gran casino!
Sono cresciuta, quindi,
con la lingua dei segni italiana
e con l'italiano parlato:
due lingue completamente diverse.
Ho imparato a parlare
grazie alla lingua dei segni.
Ogni segno corrispondeva a una parolina,
per esempio, il segno "palla"
diventava un concetto palla
e poi diventava la parola palla.
I segni e le paroline messe insieme
diventavano poi delle frasi intere.
Faccio un esempio:
Ilaria, questo è il segno-nome,
vai a prendere la palla!
Ora, sicuramente la domanda
che sorge spontanea è:
ma come può un bambino
capire la differenza
tra una vocale e una consonante?
I sordi hanno anche
delle ottime capacità visive:
quando viene a mancare un senso,
se ne sviluppano meglio altri,
tra cui la vista e, quindi,
la lettura labiale.
Le lettere dell'alfabeto
possono essere insegnate
anche attraverso il tatto.
La "mmm" di mamma, per me,
era la mia manina appoggiata
sulla guancia di mamma, "mmmmmm"
Provate anche voi a farlo: "mmmmmm".
È più facile a farsi che a dirsi.
La "elle" è visivamente facile,
perché si vede la lingua
appoggiata sul palato.
La "esse" e la "zeta", queste sconosciute
così difficili da vedersi,
da pronunciarsi e da ricordarsi
sono da sempre state il cruccio
della mia logopedista.
Ogni tanto le dimentico da qualche parte!
La "erre" ha una bellissima storia.
Mia mamma, quando mi portava
dalla logopedista
o a fare musicoterapia, in particolare,
coinvolgeva sempre mio fratello Roberto
che, con tanta pazienza, con tanto amore,
è stato una parte importante
del mio percorso di crescita.
Ci mettevano sul pianoforte,
affinché sentissi le vibrazioni
su tutto il corpo.
I suoni, la musica, i rumori
venivano insegnati sotto forma di gioco.
Toccare per mano l'arpa
e capire che faceva un rumore diverso
rispetto al tamburello,
o rispetto al pianoforte.
E questa macchinina?
Questa macchinina che mio fratello
faceva passare su tutto il corpo,
sulle braccia, sul collo, sulla schiena,
sotto il palmo dei piedi,
facendomi ridere così tanto
per il solletico,
è stata così importante!
Importante perché:
Rrrrr, Rrrr, Rrrrrrrr...
e dai, e dai, e dai,
è arrivata questa fatidica "erre".
Così da "Obetto" è diventato Roberto!
So che sei qui da qualche parte
ma non ti vedo: Grazie Roberto!
(Applausi)
In tutte le disposizioni
legislative vigenti,
il termine "sordomuto"
è stato sostituito dalla parola "sordo",
grazie alla legge
del 20 febbraio del 2006.
Questo perché le persone sorde
hanno le corde vocali integre.
E sono in grado di parlare.
Che poi uno scelga la lingua dei segni
o di parlare, o entrambe le lingue,
è una scelta libera e autonoma,
e come tale va rispettata.
Spesso chi non mi conosce,
quando mi sente parlare
per la prima volta,
mi scambia per una straniera:
ma, non so, sembri
un po' francese, spagnola,
però, cavolo, hai l'accento di Bergamo!
Signori, non chiedetemi
come faccio ad avere l'accento di Bergamo!
Non me lo so spiegare neanche io!
(Risate)
La sordità, quindi la disabilità,
nasce dal momento in cui ci si mette
in relazione con una persona sorda.
Vi è mai capitato
di incontrare persone sorde
e di non sapere magari come relazionarvi?
Sentendovi magari a disagio?
Succede.
Non si nasce a questo mondo imparati,
si impara dall'esperienze.
Le reazioni a cui assisto quando, poi,
dico che sono una persona sorda:
"Mi dispiace!"
Che poi, ti dispiace di cosa?
"Scusami non avevo capito!
Adesso provo a parlare più piano",
rendendomi la conversazione
ancora più difficile.
Diversi iniziano a urlare!
A volte la sordità sembra non esistere!
Ah ah ah, bella lì!
Non vuoi proprio sentire, eh?
La sordità a volte sparisce,
a volte invece sembra essere un luogo:
"Fammi indovinare, per caso sei francese?"
- "No, guarda sono una persona sorda".
- "Ah, interessante, e dove si trova?"
(Risate)
Quindi, come ci si relaziona
con una persona sorda?
Semplice: mettersi
davanti all'interlocutore,
parlare normalmente,
scandire le parole, se necessario
e assicurarsi che abbia capito.
Anche se la soluzione migliore, a volte,
è chiedere alla stessa persona cosa vuole,
come preferisce che le si parli.
Lei stessa vi dirà che cosa preferisce.
Da un anno e mezzo vivo a Bergamo,
in un appartamento in affitto,
e spesso la domanda
che mi viene rivolta è la seguente:
"Ma come fai a svegliarti al mattino?"
Ci sono questi dispositivi luminosi
che producono anche vibrazioni.
Io ho questa sveglia
che è grande più o meno così.
Roberto, mio fratello,
sa bene, di cosa sto parlando.
Io ho questa sveglia,
che metto sotto il cuscino.
Aveva ragione mia mamma a volte,
a dirmi, quando ero un po' più piccola:
"Tu sei sorda solo quando vuoi!"
Adesso arriviamo a parlare
della lingua dei segni.
Come tutte le lingue parlate,
la lingua dei segni è una lingua.
Contiene gli aspetti verbali
e gli aspetti non verbali,
ha una sua grammatica e una sua sintassi.
È un canale, una comunicazione
che sfrutta il canale visivo, gestuale.
Il messaggio viene espresso
attraverso i movimenti del corpo,
le espressioni del viso e le mani.
È una lingua universale?
No, la lingua dei segni
varia da paese a paese:
c'è la lingua dei segni italiana,
la lingua dei segni americana,
la lingua dei segni inglese e così via.
Oggi, l'Italia, è uno dei pochi
e ultimi paesi a livello europeo
a non vedersi riconosciuta questa lingua.
La Convenzione dell'Onu del 2006,
sui diritti delle persone con disabilità,
riconosce ufficialmente
le lingue dei segni,
promuovendone l'uso e l'acquisizione,
il mancato riconoscimento,
da parte dell'Italia,
nel riconoscere la lingua,
è una grave inadempienza
all'avvenuta ratifica italiana
di questa convenzione.
Non solo: il riconoscimento della LIS
garantirebbe a una persona
la piena libertà
di scegliere come comunicare,
di avere un effettivo accesso illimitato
a informazione, educazione, istruzione,
servizi sociali, lavorativi,
ricreativi e così via.
Non solo: per tutte quelle persone
che non conoscono la lingua dei segni -
perché, effettivamente, ci sono
anche persone che non la conoscono,
in particolare figli sordi
di genitori udenti,
che portano protesi acustiche
o impianti cocleari,
si aggiungono i mancati servizi adeguati.
La mancata accessibilità
nei diversi ambiti della vita quotidiana,
quali università, stazioni, aeroporti,
ospedali, uffici, ascensori,
caselli autostradali, musei,
teatri, cinema,
solo per citarne alcuni, eh!
I "sottotitoli" in televisione,
solo su pochi canali
e, spesso e volentieri,
solo in prima serata,
per non parlare delle dirette
dei telegiornali.
Ok, mi fermo qui che è meglio!
Tra tutte le domande,
per concludere questo viaggio insieme,
tra tutte le domande
che mi sono state fatte in questi 28 anni,
ce n'è una
che mi ha particolarmente colpito.
Mi è stata fatta
da un bambino di nove anni.
Ero in questa scuola
a parlare della mia esperienza.
La domanda chemi ha rivolto è la seguente:
"Ma se inventassero una pillola
che eliminasse per sempre la tua sordità,
e ti desse la possibilità
di diventare udente, e quindi di sentire,
la prenderesti sì o no?"
La maestra subito l'ha zittito
dicendogli: "Ma che domande fai?"
No, signori!
È stata una domanda bellissima!
Bellissima perché mi ha messo
nelle condizioni di poter riflettere.
Sono tornata indietro nel tempo,
mi si sono aperti
tutti quei flashback, come nel film,
mi rivedevo io da piccola
seduta su questo pianoforte,
con queste protesi così grandi
che mi facevano le orecchie a sventola,
a imparare a stare al mondo,
a sognare un futuro facile per noi,
a chiedermi che cosa avrei fatto
da grande, se ce l'avrei fatta,
con tutti i sacrifici fatti
per arrivare fin qui,
i pianti, i dolori, le delusioni,
i primi traguardi, il sentirsi diversa,
le frustrazioni, le sofferenze,
le conquiste, così come è stata
una grande conquista essere qui,
sul palco di TEDxBergamo 2019
davanti a voi,
immaginate quale sia stata
la mia risposta!
Grazie.
(Applausi)